you know it's crazy you can't have pit
bulls in England they consider dangerous
dogs which is just nonsense look at this
thing
how could you say that this is dangerous
[Music]
we definitely do have a group chat has
called the Holy Trinity Jacob and I met
at Jacobs audition obviously and artists
is the coop puppies have the best smell
man they're just that puppy smell
there's nothing like it
oh we instantly became really good
friends and then when I introduced him
to my best friend Harrison it was
apparent that we were gonna be really
good friends in there and that sort of
sparked this online thing called the
Holy Trinity sorry that was a terrible
answer I can't think right now we're too
distracted by the cuteness of this
little puppy right
[Music]
Chris Pratt because I get tired he's so
big he could carry me around
[Music]
sorry again I forgot the question I'm
just too into these puppies right now
can we have some more puppies in there I
think we should bring all the other
puppies in and we should definitely rip
up the paper three movies primal fear I
think my cousin Vinnie and spider-man
homecoming so I can reminisce all the
good times I would choose Atlantis and
what's the cat's name wait not the
doctor dude the view a little nippy one
yeah I probably play here in the
Explorer well I guess you don't really
need to ask for advice from these guys
because you can just watch them work and
see how the best in the business do it
oh I would probably be a stuntman but I
would never have known about the stunt
man's world if I hadn't been an actor
first or a carpenter maybe my family a
carpenters or maybe a puppy Wrangler I
seem like I'm pretty good at it Twinkies
are pretty head I tried my first Twinkie
the other day and it was disgusting and
I'll never eat one again and I actually
got a lot of hate online for not
enjoying a Twinkie okay guys that's a
bit
[Music]
I think with great power comes great
responsibility is the best quote I could
give you hey guys so this lovely
interview today the puppies have been
brought to us by Angel City pit bulls
and you can pick up one of these
incredibly cute and really noisy pit
bull puppies
I don't want to go guys
[Music]